le hunter c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui
fête son anniversaire avec sa famille il
en parle un commentaire les reçus sur
une de ses vidéos et commentaires
haineux forcément et ensuite il apprend
à tout le monde qu'on fait c'est
forcément quelqu'un de cette pièce les
plus et ce commentaire que seul truc qui
sont présents dans cette pièce ont pu
faire plein de choses notamment comme
beaucoup de gens sur internet je reçois
des commentaires en tout genre dont des
commentaires et de toujours philippe
roux est ce que c'est aussi normal sur
internet
on est sur le tournage de l'ulster pour
l'instant ça se passe très bien joué
avec des tueurs thatcher twilight est un
tueur
moi j'ai adoré ce cas c'est catherine et
nicolas retiennent la comédie-française
bon jovi que moi c'est sa famille
claudette on ne présente plus c'est la
grand-mère des technophobes était super
aussi d'avoir justin le petit voulait
vraiment quelqu'un qui soit assez
crédible sur tournage franchement
j'ouvre la porte et je la vois en larmes
et ruines du coup mais moi j'étais moi
même un petit peu ému par ce qui arrive
jamais sur mes tournages que dans les
réunions par exemple quand ludovic vous
mis sur la table ou un peu de larmes
larmes aux yeux quand même voilà la
surprise c'était vraiment dix mille à me
voir mon super aller sur tournage et
puis il a impressionné un peu tout le
monde je pense déjà rôle très important
c'est à dire voilà c'est bien passé et
je joue les frères européenne arrête
il fallait faire un nombre de plans mais
incalculable avec desserrer des larges
de moyens mon point de vue des points de
vue quand je suis debout c'est théo qui
a qui a réalisé nos engagements à l'aise
avec ce duo avec avec théo parce que lui
il va être plus sur la technique et leur
rythme et moi je vais me concentrer du
coup plus sûrs les acteur est sûre
vraiment ce qui doit être dit comment
est ce que ça raconte qu'il ya eu
quelques petites scènes de pithiviers
faut savoir que ludo propose énormément
de conneries sur un tournage
j'aimerais one nicolas mais c'est moi
nicolas enchanté je viens gentiment
alors que j'ai eu une gastro entérite je
vous passe les détails mais avec cette
scène où je découvre pauline la porte
grince et mais avec un bruit un nouveau
bruit de grâce mais on n'a jamais
entendu ce bruit de toute la vie
tout le monde était mort de rire quoi
donc c'est super dur tu avais justin
derrière en larmes je peux essayer
voilà de rester dans son perso et moi
j'ouvre la porte et là c'était super
yoko sont tus marseille en plus au
phénomène de de haine sur internet
totalement dédouanée est totalement
assumée je trouve ça fascinant parce que
sous couvert d'anonymat on peut être
tenté mois quand le gamin j'allais sur
des forums de matt pokora et je le jeu
il est vrai j'ai laissé quelques
messages qui était pas très poli tout le
monde l'a fait je les fais j'ai arrêté
depuis
eba
oui
hannezo